first of all when you're doing that ad
read i thought you're gonna say package
is a gay
what do you mean what was it was one of
those the actual sentence
packages a day oh i just
i don't know i i had like
i had like that so raven i get those
well they haven't heard the ad read yet
though that's why it's going to be funny
so i'm saying it at the top um
sorry go ahead no i had gay on my mind
because um
i actually read a statement from lgbq in
light of
you know the launch of gay burger what'd
they say
uh well let me read it yeah please do
[Music]
here at lgbq we take great pride in our
gay sauce
it's come to our attention that recent
developments in local businesses
may put our gay sauce under threat but
don't fear our gay sauce will never be
kept in the closet okay you'll never be
held down
the gay sauce will fight through keep on
keeping on and come on down to lgbq
and get your hefty pound of gay sauce
that's good that's good dude but i don't
think that
the gay sauce is actually in jeopardy
because
i guess i saw an article that elijah's
is called
jizz sauce oh
it's not but did you see that no well
you know i just
you know i think the owners of lgbq are
just afraid that
you know just they've they've
been a business for 50 years now you
know yeah right
they don't want to get swept up by the
new corporate you know
overlord that's just you know take
taking over society you know they're
just trying to preserve the lgbq
you know oh they're like a small they're
like a small business you know a gay
burger is like the big conglomerate you
know that moved in across the street
right right right right well bigger
burgers bigger but that's part of it
that's part of
you know you got to expect competition
they were they had a monopoly kind of on
the whole gay fast food industry
that's true up until this point and now
gay burger
is a thing and their gaioli sauce
yeah which that's actually on the menu
i'm pretty sure which it is
did you not literally say gaioli sauce
last week yeah
like literally three [ __ ] days before
this comes out
what are the odds of that literally
comes out
yeah exactly i just like talking about
this like it's a real topic
like we're actually sitting here
discussing the ethics of gay burger
gay fast food yeah and lgbtq but it's
they're not real
you know in a way you could argue the
owners of lgbq are
they're kind of trying to they're trying
to maintain a monopoly on the market you
know
sort of like subtly shaming gay burger
yeah
doesn't doesn't feel welcoming you know
but how did they subtly shame them
well you know to say like their gay
sauce is under attack like gay burger
didn't attack their sauce you know
they didn't attack the sauce and gay
sauce is still
it's still like a very protected recipe
people have tried to reproduce it
exactly you'll never get that creaminess
no never get that flavor
a little saltiness you know you know the
smell of ajax
it's hard to replicate elijah texted me
and said i'll send you guys
gay burger if you well he was because he
saw the people tagging us in the tweet
and he was like i don't understand what
did you guys say this and we were like i
texted him back and i was like this is
so bizarre we literally said this last
week and we even said gaoli sauce i'm
pretty sure
and uh oh the gay burger side is pulled
up yeah throw it up anyways he texted he
said i'll send you guys some tomorrow if
you want so maybe for the bone zone
because we're doing it live
today maybe we can get some gay burger
in the middle of it
and eat some there it is right there
that's [ __ ] great that's a good logo
seems pretty gay already
let's make it gayer and for charity 100
of proceeds go to the what is it la lgbt
center for homeless youth
damn 100 of the proceeds damn it's
pretty sick
yeah it's time burgers were gay grab
yours today let's see what are the
burgers called love me daddy beef me up
scotty
tell me daddy not to be confused with
love me daddy
no more milk daddy nice
gay fries extremely gay fries gay cookie
that's pretty funny wow
oh man
should have hired us to do the ad for it
yeah seriously
we could have casted our boy
[Laughter]
do it yeah like [ __ ] i like [ __ ]
gay cheeseburgers man cause i'm [ __ ]
gay
so head on down to gay barbecue i mean
excuse me gay burger and get yourself a
gay burger
cause i'm [ __ ] gay as [ __ ]
i don't eat mr beast burger all right i
gotta get back in that accent how do i
do that
mr b mr beast burger i don't need a mr
beast burger
i want a gay burger cause i'm [ __ ]
gay
i like me a cheeseburger that reminds me
of min meat
that's why i take myself the gay burger
give me a beef me up daddy
please all day
i was like going i was going on a binge
of like those tick tocks where
those dudes do those country voiceovers
it's like some it's like some popular
sound like some girl playing like
guitar dudes it's like
you know that feeling when you're
driving your forward truck
and it actually doesn't even get there
like when you're best when you're
when your best friend slides his hand
down your thigh
that feeling of driving a ford truck
i've never seen that oh man i [ __ ] i
don't i'd have to find it it's damn it
man that's so funny
that's so funny you know that feeling
of you sliding your hand through matthew
mcconaughey's hair
while you're driving through the driving
that buick
through the arizona desert
that's that feeling of driving a ford
truck
bro speaking of speaking of trucks i
just have to say
no free clout we're not going to say
we're not going to say what car brand
but a car brand went
on my dick this sunday dude i think
everyone knows
we just you know we can't say because a
yadalaq
[Laughter]
you had a lack yeah they were
[ __ ] dude hop off yeah i saw that story
i said
hop off dude i couldn't believe it man
that dude showed up with a
bread basket but it was liquor you know
the way the basket looked i was
expecting like a a live
chicken and eggs to be inside it yeah it
was so
it did kind of look like a farm like a
fresh basket
super rustic you know yeah yeah he
handed that to me and then there's like
he had a one bag of food and i said oh
man this is crazy
i was like thank you he's like nah
there's more
he comes back with two more giant bags
and then another thing of liquor and
then two boxes of beer
they stalked you with sauce it was um
it was it was crazy and luke said
they're really just trying to get me to
give the car back
yeah he's like wait he's standing under
the door waiting he's like all right
all right you're uh now your turn right
well i just closed the door on him was
like nice
man thanks appreciate it [ __ ]
yadillac dude
yeah like dude they're great cadillac
more like how to lick these
nuts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
quarantine has to end dude that's the
only thing that's giving me
entertainment now is trying to get you
to
say these dude i've got a couple stocked
up that i haven't even tried on you yet
uh-oh uh-oh
[Laughter]
just wait one of these days it's gonna
happen
i love how a d's nuts joke is now like
uh it's a very premeditated thing
oh yeah yeah it's like months of
preparation now
yeah yeah these nice joke these
like now i think is almost like doing a
a live show it's like prepping for like
a stand-up show yeah exactly
because you you know you can't mess up
the line
if there are people in the room you know
they might give it away yeah it's like
has to be a very
personal thing so i agree i've been
sitting on this one for months i'm just
waiting for the right time to drop it
but it's good it's good
this is one night one night we got drunk
and just sat around and like
said these jokes for hours
like we're all just sitting there in a
circle like looking at each other but
like doing the think face
yeah you know when you're you know what
someone's thinking and they're looking
at you but they're you can tell they're
just looking through you because they're
so in their head
yeah trying to figure something out yeah
and they're all doing that half smile
where it's like
we just were doing that we were all
drunk sitting there looking at each
other and then we go
and we turn to the next person to look
right through them and then we'd look
right and then someone would drop one
and
we'd be all like oh that's good
[Laughter]
what about this one
i think so basically you guys had like a
what what would you call that a
dad you had a brainstorm yeah you have a
brainstorm
a brainstorm a think tank think tank on
deez nuts
yeah yeah um i like brainstorm better
oh yeah because you know brainstorm
right right right yeah
i don't know what this does so you're
not thinking
i'm not [ __ ] dude
you hear about brain
no bring these nuts in your mouth
i don't know that was kind of okay yeah
yeah kind of like brain brain yeah
here uh here's one okay sam said this
one this is sam's i gotta give him all
credit for this otherwise he'll crucify
me
okay this is sam's sam shots this is his
this is a d and now a d's nuts joke by
sam shots read by cody ko
hold on i have to [ __ ] remember it
hold on no
what's the guy that crowds waiting
does a song with mac miller and he does
the song with
what the [ __ ] is his name oh my god
drummer
travis barker no super creative guys
drummer he does
tons of music artists oh my god anderson
yeah
yeah anderson pack oh yeah anderson
all right go ahead okay
he said something like and you like does
your mom like it
oh does your dad like anderson pack
that's funny because no wait wait hold
on oh
dude this is like an emmy award-winning
moment and like that's funny because
your mom and her son pack my dick in her
yeah
[Laughter]
something like that he did it you know
he did it better than me but
something like that it was pretty
i'm just going to say sam i'm kind of
disappointed in that one you you either
have to come on and read it better
it was i'm the one that butchered it you
gotta trust me that he
he got me with it pretty hard all right
all right i trust i trust
you